hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round five of this
year's European Club cup it is Magnus
Carlson versus his first uh opponent
that is rated over 2700 it is um Vincent
kimer representing chess club novor
Magnus of course representing goas spill
and uh it's a it's a game really a weird
one where we have like nine moves of
known Theory and then already on move 11
uh the position just completely opens up
and the position uh Comes Alive you'll
see what I mean by this so let's di
straight into it uh Magnus uh with the
white pieces opens with E4 and the
Vincent goes for the Sicilian Defense
Pawn to C5 Knight F3 we have D6 and now
the open Sicilian with D4 now that is a
true treat uh C captures Knight captures
Knight to F6 and now Knight to C3 and
now Pawn to A6 the Knight of Sicilian is
on the board and this is just uh I mean
this is the uh this is the best you can
get a player of of uh Vincent's strength
playing the n Sicilian against Magnus
Carlson you know that this can only end
well for one of the players so let's
check it out I mean it can end well for
for either Vincent or Magnus because a
knight of Sicilian will not be um a
docile opening so Bishop to C4 it's a
fairly standard way of treating the nro
because I always say in the nro any move
you play here with white is a very
well-known uh opening now you can't
really make a weird move with white here
any move you play is a very welln and
Bishop to C4 is like the the fourth most
popular like u i I think you go like
Bishop to G5 then you have Bishop to E2
then Bishop to E3 and Bishop to C4 being
the fourth most popular option but still
very very strong Bishop to C4 we have E6
makes sense as the bishop is now on this
long diagonal uh and now Pawn to A4
stopping Pawn to B5 from Vincent we have
Bishop to E7 and both players Castle so
Castle's castles uh and now Bishop to E3
and there are a couple of games
where uh the position has has been
reached Knight to C6 is a on move B6 is
a nor move but the move Vincent plate is
a new one so it is now as of move nine
that we have a completely new game and
now look at this queen to E2 of course
you have to defend your Bishop on C4
Bishop to D7 again a very well-known
move in the Knight of Cilan you want to
play Knight to C6 you want to trade off
your knight for this Knight and you want
to put your light scare Bishop on this
long diagonal so that's that's the idea
put additional pressure on D4 and take
it from there next you're going to play
B6 maybe get the Knight into the game
and get the Rook to C8 so those are some
of your moves that you are hoping to
play but now Magnus plays Pawn to A5 and
you already have to be careful now you
with the B6 Square being covered by the
pawn and the Knight not having access to
D7 you have to worry about Bishop to B6
in some lines and the standard way of
treating this would be Knight to C6 or
Rook to d8 or something um in that
fashion but Vincent played Knight to G4
which is again a very well-known Concept
in the Knight of Sicilian you want to
maneuver the Knight with Tempo you
attack the bishop then the bishop I
removes or you know okay sometimes you
even capture it but all in all you want
to get your knight to E5 that's the
point but here in this particular uh you
know uh order of moves it does not work
uh and I'm not going to tell you why you
guys will tell me why feel free to pause
the video and try to find uh well I dare
I say it a winning move for Magnus while
I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you must
be a true student of how to play against
the nro as this is not easy to spot and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Knight to F5 now what's
uh what's the idea behind Knight to F5
well uh black just can't do anything uh
weird like if you play Knight captures
on E3 then Knight captures on E7 already
comes with check so first you have to T
to that and after the king moves you're
going to play F captures on E3 and now
once uh well you have have to attack the
Knight otherwise you're just down a
piece so you have to play Queen to d8
and then the Knight goes back Knight to
F5 and now the question is can you
capture the Knight here yes you can but
it's not going to be great for example
Pawn captures on E5 and now you're going
to play Pawn captures on E5 with the F6
coming uh not uh the the best position
if you play something like F6 okay
you've played it but now these pawns are
weak and you're weak on this diagonal
and positionally this is lost and a
strong player will be able to take
advantage of this very easily so you
can't really ignore your Bishop here
being attacked if you play e captures on
F5 of course you can do that you just um
accept the challenge then comes Knight
to D5 again attacks the que queen and
the undefended bishop on E7 and once you
defend it uh then comes Bishop to B6
attacking your queen and once you move
it then comes Knight to C7 attacking the
queen and the rook and once the queen
moves this is the only Square you
captured The Rook you're now up the
exchange of course you will have um a
winning game for example captures
captures and now even Bishop to D3 is
coming so you're probably going to move
the Knight Knight E5 still you can play
this as the bishop on E7 is hanging and
we can do some trades here let's say
captures captures Queen captures on C2
you're going to play Queen captur on D6
and all in all okay Five Points each but
you are up the exchange and the Knight
has a very clear way of re-entering the
game Knight C7 Knight D5 and uh of
course white wins so instead Vincent
plays Bishop to F6 which is the most
resilient way of facing Knight to 5 and
it is the top move recommended by the
engine uh and now Magnus plays Bishop to
B6 we have Queen to C6 and now uh Magnus
played Knight to D4 but I'm just going
to show you a move that completely
shatters Black's position uh Knight to
D4 is also very nice and it is
objectively winning uh but there is
there is a move that um uh well either
either a super engine or or or tal would
play and that is of course Bishop to D5
as now the black queen has no square
uh other than the C8 square but if you
go Queen to C8 then of course you trap
the queen with Knight captures on D6 as
the D6 Pawn is undefended so you really
can't play that after Bishop D5 you
would have to take the bishop and after
e captures now you would play e captures
attack the queen and once the queen
moves let's say go Queen to C8 again
Knight captures on D6 and you don't lose
the queen but you have to play Bishop to
B5 in order to clear the D7 Square for
the queen uh then you would capture here
the Queen's still hanging now Queen
comes to D7 you're going to play Knight
to C7 and okay you capture here Queen
captures and G4 next move you also
captur The Rook this is completely
crushing so only way for black to play
this at least somehow after this um e
captures on D5 is to play Queen captures
on C3 and give up the queen for some
counterplay for example Pawn captures
and Bishop captures on F5 and okay you
can maybe try and hold this with black
but it's um objectively it is a lost
game but Magnus goes for a different
move uh he goes for Knight to D4 again
harassing the queen queen to C8 and now
he plays Bishop to B3 so a bit slower
than the line that we've shown Knight to
E5 and now Rook a to D1 we have Bishop
to d8 now challenging this very strong
Bishop here and pawn to F4 challenging
the Knight on E5 we have Knight E to C6
and now we have Pawn to F5 now preparing
Pawn to F6 but also just uh start
capturing here as the bishop also
attacks the6 Square
uh Bishop captures on B6 a captures and
now Knight captures on D4 we have Rook
captures on D4 and now Vincent creates a
pin here with Queen to C5 but just Queen
to F2 by Magnus e captures on F5 e
captures on F5 again preparing Pawn to
F6 and now uh how do you play this it
seems like you could play this uh
because if Queen captures on F5 then
Queen captures on D4 comes with check uh
problem is here you have Knight to A4
attacks the queen kicks the queen away
from this diagonal and then you just
pick up the free Bishop here uh so
instead uh Bishop to C6 was played and
now Pawn to F6 completely opening up the
king if you play G6 then Queen D2 and
this will not end well for black so
Knight to D7 now Vincent tries to uh get
get the Knight into the game but just F
captures King captures and now even
Bishop to D5 cutting off the black queen
from uh helping out with the defense of
the king and while you could capture the
Knight captures again it's not it's
really not great if pon F6 uh trying to
create some sort of a defense here at B4
of course what else did you expect the
queen is attack Queen C6 Knight C7 and
everything hangs this hangs uh this uh
again is a threat of a fork here
attacking the rook and the King you
cannot play this as Knight also covers
d8 Square so not happening so after
Bishop to D5 F5 was attempted by Vincent
H but now a very clean um solution to
the position Bishop captures Queen
captures on C6 and now Rook F to D1 one
Hing in on Black's true weakness which
is the D6 Pawn as it often is in Knight
of Sicilian so that's why we often say
you should advance that pawn to D5 if
you if you can do it with black then
everything should be okay uh Queen
captures on B6 but now Knight to D5
chasing away the queen from this
diagonal uh we have Queen to d8 if Queen
captures on B2 yes you can play this but
then again Knight C7 attacks The Rook
threatening Knight to E6 check this is
resigns so after Knight D5 Queen to d8
was played and now Magnus just played
Knight to F4 and he was in this position
and move 29 that Vincent kimer resigned
the game as there really is nothing more
to be done here Magnus is threatening a
monster Royal Fork here attacking the
Queen the rook and the king and there's
no good way to deal with this if Queen
F6 then you uh Fork the king and the
queen here if you play Queen to E7 it's
possible uh but then look at this Rook
captures on D6 threatens the Knight here
if you move the Knight then Rook E6 you
threaten the queen and if Queen F7 uh
then you go in for the k kill Rook
captures on F6 King capture if you
capture with the queen again this Forks
Fork wins the queen so King captures and
now of course it's um uh it's uh just um
King hunt Queen to D4 with check King to
G5 Rook to D3 now going in for the kill
King to H6 and now Rook to H3 with check
King to G5 Rook to H5 with check you're
going to play King to G4 H3 check King
G2 and Knight D2 will be Checkmate so
this is only one of the possible lines
of course Vincent sees that uh the storm
is looming over him and he says no more
I've had it 29 moves is enough for any
man uh so there we have it uh four out
of four for Magnus uh and uh I mean
really really incredible against a top
player like Vincent Vincent is currently
like a world number 26 in classical
chess I mean it's uh uh no known Theory
up until this point Queen to C7 was a
known move in in in top tier games and
then already two moves after that
Vincent completely loses with with
Knight to G4 Knight to F5 completely
crushing Magnus finds it and I mean what
a move I don't know if Magnus considered
Bishop to D5 here instead of Knight to
D4 this uh really really wild like I
said it's either a super engine move or
a tall move uh but uh maybe he just
didn't like the line where where Vincent
gives up the queen and then Magnus has
to go for it and maybe he thought okay
this is a positionally this is safest
and I'm still going to win it so who
knows maybe he mentioned it in in an
interview I didn't watch it if you guys
have seen it do share in the comment
section below uh and also if you guys
are interested in the current world
standings we haven't shown those in a
while uh here they are uh so yeah you
have of course Magnus number one for for
like forever with 2847 he's currently on
plus 8.7 so almost closing in on that
2850 Bobby ding Nakamura ala J sh gir
Wesley so GES and R rort are in the
world top 10 an lost some points now
because I know yesterday he overtook
gkes um and re-entered the top 10 but I
guess today he lost uh and then lost
some points kakin Dominguez Perez rajab
of
Taman
mukang mvl wesling topalo still almost
in the top 20 21 then Wei Yang Shish
Duda and so on and so on so yeah very
nicely done very impressive game by
Magnus but it was like I said incredibly
ra going for the nro which is the
sharpest possible Sicilian you could
play against the the highest rated
player in the world uh you know props
the Vincent but you know well you you've
seen what happened uh so yeah that's the
game really hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Magnus going going
hard with 100% here nicely done I would
like to thank ala DMO is the best data
Lake engine K Kate Ingram Dennis chano
and the Mr hoodie guy for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and sorry for
my for my voice I'm I I am I have
something I don't know what but it's
affecting my voice so uh see you
soon